[Music]
welcome back to this special edition of
Hannity in October US ambassador to the
United Nations nikki Haley announced she
would be resigning her position at the
United Nations at the end of the year
yesterday ambassador Haley spoke with
Shaun about her time at the UN her
working relationship with President
Trump and much much more tickler hi
joining us now is US ambassador to the
UN former governor Nikki Haley's host
and bats are good to see you
congratulations you know I look over the
last two years little less than two
years what do I see we saw what's
happened in North Korea Jerusalem is now
the capital of Israel it's now been
moved to its proper home we've watched
Isis being shut down the Iranian
sanctions have been put in place and
seem effective American strength abroad
I would argue has never been stronger
but you have the front row seat so am i
right my perceptions I mean America has
found her voice back again it is a good
time for America in the world now for
some countries that's a good thing and
for some countries that's a bad thing
for Americans that's a great thing
because I think what we've basically
seen is that it was time for us to start
talking about what we believed in and
what we didn't when I came in they had
just had a Cuban sponsored resolution
that was anti-american that basically
blamed America for everything and the
United States abstained on that vote I
came in after they did the anti-israel
bias and instead of standing up for our
friends in Israel we again abstained on
our vote this is a new day in a new time
where we don't abstain you know exactly
where the United States stands you know
what we're for you know what we're
against and you know where we're going
and so I think there's a lot of moral
clarity in for the United States now and
I think countries appreciate that we're
now very straightforward
I've watched an interview and you talk
about your relationship with the
president it sounds to me correct me if
I'm wrong like it was a good cop bad cop
routine like you would use whatever the
issue was you would use his strength
that he would go out and and
combative it seems like the world
leaders believe him when he says
something and that you would use that in
your negotiations as explain to how the
dynamic work well I think the only thing
is I didn't make him out to be the bad
cop what I said was this is where the
president is unless we get this done I
can't promise you where he's gonna go
because he's upset and we need to move
forward I have the president I have a
great relationship it was a great
partnership we respected each other I
let him be him I turn around and just
used his unpredictability as an
advantage because it is for many who say
people don't know what to expect from
the United States that's not a bad thing
and so I use that as leverage I used
that as ways of getting us what we
needed and he was always great in making
sure that he never let anybody get
comfortable and so I I always saw it as
a great working relationship I find that
though is it may be a good cop bad cop
was a bad phrase maybe the way to say it
though is he likes to keep everybody on
his toes and he knows exactly what he's
doing that's what I have discovered do
you agree with absolutely absolutely in
every what way whatsoever
you know his strong point really is
communicating to leaders around the
world and I would always tell the
President and strongly believe if you
get him in front of any world leader he
wins them he completely wins them and if
any world leader threatens the United
States
he puts the absolute fear of God into
them and you know for me it is the
reason our foreign policy is so strong
it's the reason why we or have been so
effective is because the president has
said very clearly what he will do what
he won't do but most importantly he
stood by it when he said if they used
chemical weapons there would be price to
pay and then he followed through with it
that said a lot to the international
community that you can't take this
president what's funny to me is if NATO
doesn't believe that we might pull back
on some of our we pays what seventy two
cents of every dollar and the president
is challenging them to pay more if
Mexico Canada China and our European
allies if they don't believe the
president is really going to there's
really going to be consequences as
relates to trade deals they'll never
negotiate so I think there is a there's
a force of the wisdom sort of like the
art of the deal and I know everybody
gets panicked like they I think there
was a lot of panic over a little Rocket
Man
my buttons bigger than yours and you
know fire and fury but look at where we
now have an opportunity of having the
entire Korean Peninsula nuclear-free how
well tell you first of all look at NATO
now all the countries are paying more so
what he did worked when you look at
North Korea it was that rhetoric
combined with general McMaster at the
NSC at the time calling different
countries telling them to you know expel
diplomats not to allow them to have
embassies and then all of that work
allowed for us to get those sanctions
done at the United Nations and so I will
tell you while people didn't like what
he was saying or how he was saying it
what it allowed me to do is say he's
being honest
he's very truthful we need to pass these
sanctions or I can promise you if there
is a threat he will respond I agree with
you about the Saudi Arabia situation and
I find that people have been far too
simplistic in their analysis of it it's
far more complicated than that
and I I believe he's responsible I in my
heart I think the evidence will show
eventually if it has not already I
obviously don't have access to that kind
of intelligence but there's also other
things and we've got to look
contextually through history we had to
align with Stalin in World War two to
defeat Hitler a mass murderer but we did
I look at the emerging alliance of the
United States Israel the Saudis
Jordanians Egyptians Emirates against
Iranian hegemony as maybe a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity to thread
a needle it is frustrating that they did
this I've been probably the loudest
critic against Saudi Arabia for years
treatment of women gays and lesbians
persecution of Christian and Jews
I don't know the answer but I think
there's it's far more complicated it's
actually believing that they did this to
Khashoggi what are your thoughts it's a
very complicated situation but it is one
that can be handled and can be solved
first of all if you have Saudi officials
going into a Saudi consulate the Saudi
government is responsible which makes
NBS responsible period that's just what
we know secondly our United States
principles values will not allow us to
give them a pass and we shouldn't and I
think that the president made a good
first step when he sanctioned the 17
individuals I think we need to continue
to have harsh conversations with the
Saudis about how this doesn't fit the
means of international norms it's not
accepted by the United States and we
can't continue to partner with someone
that continues to brutalize people in
this way and I think we have to decide
what accountability is going to look
like for them but at the same time when
we talk about the Houthis in Yemen when
we talk about Hezbollah and Lebanon when
we talk about Iran and their role in
Syria we cannot look at Saudi Arabia and
not see that they've been such a good
partner with us on that and so there are
two different avenues we need she can be
done absolutely yeah and so you know
this is a fine line we have to walk we
just have to do both they have to know
where they stand on how where we stand
on what they did but we also have to be
able to go and say okay how are we going
to continue to push Iran back from all
of this terrorist activity